encore
6 matches toulouse
mais qu'a voulu dire le président
ukrainien dans cette vidéo publiée le 14
février sur le moment la déclaration de
volodymyr zelensky a été prise très au
sérieux par les dirigeants et médias
occidentaux pour le porte-parole de la
diplomatie américaine et les traces de
jean yves le drian ministre français des
affaires étrangères a lui déclaré le
soir même yat-il tous les éléments pour
que soit mené une offensive forte de la
part des forces russes en ukraine oui
c'est vrai c'est possible là c'est
possible rapidement quelques heures plus
tard le porte parole du président
ukrainien a précisé que hélène ce qui
faisait seulement référence à des
articles journalistiques et non à des
informations tangibles mardi 15 février
la russie a ordonné le retour dans leurs
garnisons d'unités déployées près de la
frontière ukrainienne après un entretien
entre vladimir poutine et le chancelier
allemand olaf schulze entre cent et cent
trente mille soldats russes serait
cependant toujours massés à la frontière
avec l'ukraine l'annoncé a été prise
avec précaution par le secrétaire
général de l'otan des skins
folk rocheuses opte maison